aa
[Musique]
à
pas
[Musique]
à l'origine d'un mythe se trouve souvent
une profession il parole divine qui dit
le héros dans ses actes la prophétie
d'apollo énonce que la ville qui
accueillera oedipe sera bénie ce
vieillard aveugle et déchu qui attire
les malheurs possède du pouvoir dans
prémunir au tour à la fin de sa vie
oedipe en ces endroits de la cité de
thèbes est accueilli à athènes par le
roi de taizé qui en se montrant
charitable cherche aussi à protéger sa
ville et son trône contre l'opinion
d'une partie des athéniens oedipe
s'installe avec ses filles antibes nice
même le quartier de colin pour se faire
accepter le vieil homme plaide son
statut de victime
une prophétie qui le dépasse
[Musique]
cette fin du 8e des biens bien me
reconnais que les épisodes de nantes est
de la sphinge révèle une autre dimension
du héros en rachetant les fautes des
athéniens de grâce à son sacrifice
oedipe devient une figure christique
avant l'heure et sa mort surnaturel donc
personne est témoin ajoute un aspect
sacré au récit oedipe christ archaïque
donc
pourtant ce n'est pas cette facette du
personnage qui nous restent en mémoire
un dénommé jésus a fait mieux depuis
oedipe reste pour nous celui qui
contraint pas la volonté des dieux tua
son père lajos pour épouser sa mère
jocaste cette fixation sur un épisode du
mythe provient de l'une de ces
réappropriation celle qu'on a fait freud
pour la discipline qu'il fonde la
psychanalyse bien loin de la grèce c'est
à vienne en autriche en 1900 que freud
de repenser cette histoire il voit dans
les atrocités commises par le jeune roi
la traduction universel de l'amour de
l'enfant pour l'un de ses parents et de
sa haine pour l'autre c'est au prix de
cette simplification de la réduction du
récit à un seul épisode qui peut être
gravé dans nos mémoires
freud en découpant les passages qui
l'intéressé dans la pièce de sophocle a
du même coup assuré leur survie dans
l'imaginaire collectif
ce que subissent les récits
mythologiques les citer le connaissent
aussi balancé entre tab et athènes
l'histoire d'oedipe nous montre le
devenir très différent de ces deux lieux
mythiques athènes acceptant de recevoir
le vieil homme maudit se donne
elle restera le lieu de la rédemption ce
qu'il faut retenir
ted qui voit se dérouler sur son sol les
crimes 1,16 farissier fratricide élan
passe devra sombrer dans l'oubli et la
réalité archéologiques appuyé cette
opposition athènes la merveilleuse dont
les temples rayonne à face d'un monde ne
pourra jamais être oublié en figeant une
partie de la ville en idéalisant sa
forme à la manière d'un récit et en
mettant en avant ses plus belles pièces
elles ces garanties et l'éternité thème
n'aura pas fait ce choix ou n'en n'aura
pas eu l'occasion par les deux thèmes à
un étranger et vous évoquerez dans le
meilleur des cas pas plus qu'un bref
souvenir de la lecture dans type e taib
à cela de paradoxal qu elle est l'une
des cités les plus évoqués par la
mythologie et celles étant la plus
dépourvus de vestiges archéologiques
sophocle disait qu'elle était la seule
cité ou des mortels d'un naissance à des
dieux et pour cause elle est le lieu
d'origine des plus grands héros de la
mythologie comme héraclès ou encore deep
thème la maudite ne conserve presque
aucun vestige de son passé antique
ici pas d'acropole pas de sanctuaires
majestueux au mieux quelques traces
qu'il faut savoir lire dans un désordre
de fondations et de structures
postérieur
au dessus de la ville antique des tours
médiévales des routes des terrasses une
chose est frappante quand vient en tête
c'est que cette ville mythique et comme
un mythe elle-même réécrite transformer
ne laissant apparaître que quelques
morceaux originaux noyé dans les
réappropriations ultérieure taib a
changé et on l'a oublié ou presque
pourtant tu es bête une ville de
première importance dans l'antiquité par
sa position centrale dans la plaine de
béotie est un point de passage obligé
pour celui qui traverse le pays
taib même s'il n'en reste presque rien
posséder des murailles cyclopéenne
protégeant du palais mycéniens ah ouais
ouais c'est bien près on va si on passe
le long du sur les bords du lac
on verra si un beau point de vue
[Musique]
on sait aussi par les textes que tu
aimes et est un haut lieu oraculaire un
lieu où l'on venait consulter les dieux
pour connaître son destin
l'épisode de la rencontre entre oedipe
et la singe devant les murailles de la
ville prend alors tout son sens
nimbées de mystère des bêtes une cité où
s'entend la parole divine
oedipe et prédestiné par les dieux a tué
son père et a épousé sa mère effrayée à
juste titre car cette prophétie
ses parents décident de se débarrasser
de ce rejeton maudit en offrant aux
prédateurs mais oedipe est recueilli et
élevé par des bergers
il grandit donc dans l'ignorance que ses
origines de retour athènes
il triomphe de la sphinge qui fait le
siège de la cité la sphinge c'est cette
créature mélangeant les traits d'une
femme d'une lionne et d'un oiseau elle
terrorise les habitants de thèbes frma
cité au reste du monde
grâce à cette énigme quel est l'animal
qui marche sur quatre pattes le matin
deux à midi et trois le soir
réponse l'homme qui marche à quatre
pattes bébé puis sur deux adultes et
enfin qui sait d'une canne
lorsqu'il est via oedipe en résolvant
l'énigme libertés' ben et en devient le
souverain accomplissant du même coup son
destin celui du fils de roi de thèbes
abandonné à la naissance et qui prend
possession par un moyen détourné de ce
qui aurait dû lui appartenir de son
couronnement sonne comme la consolation
de son déracinement
mais le revers de ce succès est un
parricide un ans est une mutilation est
finalement un exil il tuera son père
couchera avec sa mère se creusera les
yeux et s'exilera hâte une histoire
tragique que les dieux avaient envisagé
ayant même mis en garde les géniteurs de
deep
mais comme souvent dans le domaine du
mythe il n'est pas possible d'échapper à
son destin
si cette explication est un terreau très
riche pour la pensée psychanalytique
elle est pourtant très éloignée de la
pensée grecque du 5e siècle avant notre
ère car audi proie est une oeuvre
littéraire appartenant à la culture
grecque antique et dont l'auteur
sophocle à lui même sans doute
retravailler une légende
theben bien plus ancienne et
préexistantes à la cité
le dip qu'un médecin de la fin du 19e
siècle sont imaginés et que l'on
s'imagine encore aujourd'hui n'est pas
celui des athéniens du 5e siècle avant
notre ère cette histoire nous la lisons
et la répétons allongé sur un divan
tandis que les grecs anciens l'écoutais
et la regarder lors de représentations
théâtrales le cadre historique mental et
social a changé entre sophocle
finalement cette oeuvre telle qu'elle a
été pensée unis morale ni psychologique
ou uniquement tragique
là où nous voyons un parricide
c'est de la légitime défense dont il
s'agit est là où convenance est il est
surtout question d'un mariage un peser
l'image la plus terrifiante du mythe
d'oedipe roi n'est pas celle de
l'inceste ou celle du meurtre du 1er mai
celle d'un homme saoul crevant les yeux
pour ne pas voir la réalité quand on y
pense c'est assez étrange diriger comme
figure de proue de tout un pan de la
psychanalyse celle d'un aveugles
volontaires bien sûr limites ont
toujours été des objets malléable qui
traverse les époques
c'est leur rôle après tout ils sont
simplement dont ma pensée
rasée par alexandre le grand pour avoir
refusé de se soumettre la ville de
thèbes a perdu sa place dans le monde
grec
cela explique qu'elles ne soient plus
sur la carte du tourisme du grand public
déchus comme le dit pas la fin de sa vie
liant pour elle que l'écho d'une
lointaine renommée terni depuis
longtemps mais si ted et comme les
mythes qui s'y sont jouées alors son
histoire n'est pas terminée
ce décor n'attend plus qu'une nouvelle
fable pour lui redonner une place dans
notre imaginaire
[Musique]